hey guys Pete here I'm gonna do my Game
of Thrones Saturday preview video that I
had planned even though I know that by
this point episode four has leaked and a
lot of people have seen it already but
the video I had planned has some
historical context anyways that you
might not have been aware of I just ask
again if you've watched the episode
that's fine just don't spoil it for
everybody else we'll have plenty of time
to talk about episode 4 on Monday so
kind of split on the idea all the way
around I mean I understand people want
to see it they're hyped up that's cool
but just remember that not everybody has
and you know the experience can be
ruined if you know what's going to
happen alright so this episode coming up
is the shortest episode in gay maternes
history from what I understand like I
know it was the shortest episode of this
season but I read somewhere that it's
actually the shortest one of all time
and that made me think that maybe this
battle wasn't going to happen but it
doesn't really matter because we know at
some point Daenerys is going to unleash
these dragons so everybody's been
referring to that battle as the field of
fire 2.0 the field of fire is an actual
battle in the fake history of Westeros
fake in the sense that it's made up
obviously but it's real to the world
that we're watching so this happened way
back when Aegon the first Targaryen came
to Westeros to conquer it he landed at
what would become King's Landing and set
off on a campaign to take over the
continent things were going pretty well
he rolled through Harrenhal croc claw
point and storms end and ended up in the
river land that's a stony set so before
I get any deeper into this actual battle
let me say to show only Watchers that
this is historical but it there's a
reason that I'm mentioning all this
stuff because of the people who are
involved in what happened after so it's
not really that important if you don't
remember exact details here or you don't
know where the stone except is I mean
it's southwest of Harrenhal and you know
whatever that's not the biggest most
important thing here what is important
is that Loren the first Lannister
who was king of the rock at the time
join forces with Mern gardener who was
the king of the reach and they attempted
to smash the Targaryen and push them
back so they lined up all their men
between them they had about 55,000 of
them and the Targaryen had mostly
conscripted people from the Riverlands
they didn't have their own army that
they you know that they brought in like
Daenerys has they came and crushed
things and different Lords would take up
with them because they knew they were
going to win kind of thing so yeah the
Lannisters and the Gardiners had fifty
five thousand men five thousand of those
were mounted Knights and their plan was
to flank the Targaryen army and smash
the egg on center with all those Knights
but it didn't quite work out the tart
forces were able to form a defensive
Crescent and when the app you know the
allies from the rock and from the reach
started to break their lines Aegon and
his two sisters took to their dragons
now you remember Aegon rode balerion the
black dread and his two sister wives
rode MARAC seized and veigar they
basically set the field on fire this is
the stew named the field of fire they
attacked they caught things on fire
downwind from where their enemies forces
were because of the set up their forces
were safely upwind from all the flame
and they could basically just pick
people off that were running away from
the fire King Lorne was able to escape
once he realized that there was no way
they could win the Dragons themselves
killed about 4,000 men and including
King Mern and all of his sons grandsons
brothers cousins and other kin and one
of the interesting things about this is
that in the book Game of Thrones the
first time we actually hear about this
is from Tyrion at ease travelling north
to the wall with John so to not get too
detail-oriented I guess if they crush
them the dragons crushed a much larger
force and it pretty much set precedent
for anyone who was thinking about going
up against Aegon now that doesn't mean
that the whole place folded but it was a
decisive victory for example the
Targaryen only lost like a hundred
people compared to you know thousands on
the other side it's also the only time
when all three of the dragons took the
battlefield at the same time and like I
said it has been remembered as the field
of fire
so after this all happened they took all
the swords of the defeated soldiers and
they sent him down river to Blackwater
rush to what was then known as Aegon
fort and they would end up being part of
Aegon Iron Throne the same one we know
today so that's an interesting bit the
king of the rock Lauren the first
Lannister was captured the next day he
gave up his claim he became the warden
of the West under the rule of House
Targaryen carlin Tyrells then
surrendered the seat of Highgarden to
the crown to the new crown without
conflict since all of the gardener's
were gone that's how they became that's
how they got dominion over the reach and
became the lords of Highgarden the
Tyrells and then Aegon march north now
this is where the Starks come in they
pulled together about thirty thousand
Northman and they were coming south
under the leadership of Torrance Stark
who we've been talking about quite a bit
lately he was the king in the north and
now the tables had been turned because
Aegon and his sister were able to put
together forty five thousand from the
Riverland storm land the reach and the
westerland's in response so after the
field of fire and Harrenhal falling
before that this is what made turin
become the king that nel he decided to
give up in faith of what would be the
same kind of slaughter that the
Lannisters and gardeners had face so he
became the warden of the north and
that's how all of that stuff happened so
in the current season and especially in
relation to the latest trailer that came
out we can see that
Daenerys looked super strong when she
came across but things aren't going her
way so far the crown has actually been
pretty effective with the help of euron
greyjoy to destroy her allies Daenerys
has been talked out of taking her
dragons and going to even the score by
her advisers but after seeing the last
trailer I figured that there is
basically no chance that that's kind of
hold anymore she's not going to sit at
Dragonstone and let her armies be picked
apart so this is where we imagine that
we're going to see the field of fire -
when she reintroduces dragons into the
warfare on the continent so we saw the
setup the Lannisters took Highgarden
Alana - Tyrell committed suicide and
they're traveling back with a lot of
gold and a lot of supplies that will
keep King's Landing healthy during a
siege if that would be the case the
speculation has been that this will come
under attack this convoy and that
Daenerys will make a statement that
could have the same kind of impact on
the war for Westeros as it did during
the conquest we have Jon Snow who has
not bent the knee because of his people
and he knows they won't respect that but
then we also have this historical
context where his ancestor thanks to me
in not exactly the same situation but
under the same kind of pressure so this
could change the outlook of some of the
people in the north when the word gets
back but it's like I said that's a lot
different because of the fact that John
really just only cares about going north
and battling the White Walkers Daenerys
has given him the opportunity to get
that dragonglass that he wants so it may
never really come up again in that same
context you know something may happen
where they just have to drop all those
ideas of who's following who and you
know fight the war for the dawn
basically we also have the historical
context that the Lannisters are looking
pretty good sitting on the crown right
now but then we also have the context
that Laura in the first lannister the
king of the rock is like the poster boy
for getting destroyed by dragons in bad
so yeah it's pretty interesting when you
think about all that stuff I hope you
guys if you haven't seen it yet and
you're still waiting I hope this helps
to build the hype I thought there would
be a battle for Highgarden or we'd see
more of that so I'm assuming that this
is going to be unbelievable like we know
that they were filming in this location
for like three weeks I think it was like
it's a little bit it's been a while
since I read about it but yeah it was
they were there for a long time and they
trained a lot of people they hired a lot
of extras that were you know they were
like asking for people that had combat
experience or stuff like that you know
it's definitely battle scene stuff but
they were getting together and it was on
a scale that was pretty freaking large
so it should be a spectacle
the dragons are a lot bigger than what
we've seen in the past so this should be
epic I don't know what else to say now
I'm getting all excited so I'll cut the
video off here and I will ask you to
like it if you enjoyed it tell me about
your predictions for how this field of
fire the field of fire 2.0 will compare
to the original please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and make
sure you tick the little bell for the
notifications because I've been putting
out a lot of videos and you don't want
to miss any make sure you follow me over
on Twitter and my other social media
accounts and as always thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon
you